let's talk about bill burr in this
context so we have this story from
cbr the mandalorian bill bird defends
gina carano slams cancel culture
comedian actor and podcaster bill burke
calls out the toxic nature of cancel
culture and defends his fired
mandalorian co-star gina carano
well good for him absolutely but this
story
about gina chrono exactly exemplifies
what you were just saying about
why take the risk you sound 20 you sign
with one of these companies they could
just snap their fingers and fire you
because you said
a word someone didn't like at some point
maybe in six months maybe a year
take it away as quick as they gave it to
you yeah and and the problem is
let's say you sign a deal that says like
maybe maybe they're buying you out
or maybe they're like okay we're gonna
buy your
show we'll own it and we'll pay you this
large amount of money
and it's like here's the money up front
for the show and then you'll get x
amount of dollars to continue producing
the show as lead producer executive
and then they also have a morality
clause where it says if you do
anything obscene they could terminate
you you're like i got this really great
deal it's awesome
let's be real joe rogan i'd have to
imagine that
spotify has some control in that regard
yeah where they could you know be like
oh look what you said and you know we
don't want to necessarily you know talk
about joe's deal because who the hell
knows but i think that it
all of this stuff it's they want to take
this as just a given
you know that old thing where it's like
these people think they can just move
chess pieces around
and you know people don't react to what
happens but
the truth is like i know people with
normal jobs and they go there and they
make them sign the clauses about what
they put on twitter and what they put on
facebook and you go
this is people are starting to realize
this when they get this
now the same way that if someone gives
you a job and you go oh it's 50 miles
away from my house that's going to be a
bit of a pain
the same way you're getting a contract
that says oh you know you can't be on
twitter you can do this
so all it takes is for other companies
to realize like there's monetary values
on
all of these things if i go yeah okay i
get 60 grand here for whatever you know
my
middle job or whatever but i'm allowed
to say whatever i want or this place is
offering
you know 765 grand but they kind of is
this five grand worth me not but that
but a lot of people don't i think people
are starting to
factor these things intrinsically the
you know the level of what these places
are asking for you they want you to act
like you're the president to work at a
freaking
bank well let me read a little bit from
bill burr to show you what he said uh
for those unfamiliar gina carano
she was one of the stars on the
mandalorian disney plus show it's a star
wars show
and she posted on instagram the the
photo she used was of actual nazi
germany probably not a good photo to use
but the context was don't demonize your
neighbors
over their political views she didn't
compare anybody to republicans she
actually just posted the amazon logo
yeah it was just the amazon logo yeah
but but uh here's what bill burr said
they said on the bill burt podcast he
said she was an absolute sweetheart
super effing
uh super nice effing person unless she
did some truly horrible ish or said
something over
some overtly racist ish he continued i
don't know i think there is just too
many channels
and then you gotta do sensational ish i
don't know what the f it is
i'm on that effing show now i gotta
watch what the f i say
i think that was that was that was
actually great on billboard's part yeah
but
that represents the every man but that's
the point they could cancel him for this
they could cancel him for this
he's probably got a morality clause in
his contract that says if you say
something offensive
but who defines offensive so he comes to
the fence of gina chrono saying she was
super effing nice
oh give me two seconds for some woke
left us to get angry and then disney's
gonna be like bill
you can't come out and defend this stuff
and they're probably not gonna do it
but they could if they want to who in
their right mind would sign a dumb
contract like that well this is for for
him specifically he doesn't need these
things and he's in the position of power
a little bit
where if they go oh we kick him off this
show he go and whatever okay whatever
that's the tenth thing i do you know
what i mean so
there there's like a power dynamic when
it stops being something you need
and something that you could do or not
do there is a bigger issue there
the cascade effect if he gets cancelled
from the show
and then disney issued a statement
saying he he defended racist comments
and was extremely offensive and we had
no choice
then other companies might be like look
there's a backlash going on we don't
want to absorb any of that
you know not to just be like the
complete like free marketing sorted out
guy
but yeah and if that happens the next
generation of people like me and my
friends
are gonna be like no don't take a job on
those places dude do you remember what
happened to bill burr that's exactly
what's happening right now
exactly exactly what we're saying yes i
won't this is why i don't sign any of
these contracts
i know that if i sign any of these deals
with any one of these networks it'll
it's a matter of time i don't even trust
you live like that
i don't even trust these conservative
networks that i don't i don't think they
would have your back if you said
something
truly well also even if they will right
now
in this context of like the culture war
dynamic what does that look like in a
year and a half i don't know man things
change pretty quickly
yeah i mean maybe i i i would i would i
would argue many of the conservative
channels have much more integrity than
many of the
traditional hollywood type stuff i just
wouldn't sign the deals
ideally in my you know what i've kind of
said i like the idea of a
on like a non-partisan network
to begin with like even when like think
about music it's kind of like what you
want is
uh like a guy that's like hey i don't
really get it but the kids seem to not a
not a guy that like has a lot to say to
you what you want is a network
that's like yeah people seem to
responding to this it's funny or you
know tim seems to have a big audience
people like it we should get him on
a person who's going to be like oh so we
host this one guy the left hates him
he's really offensive we don't know a
whole lot about you know
we don't care too much it makes money
for us we do have this lefty guy in our
network though and he does these things
the conservatives really hate him
when you want somebody who approaches
like a business that's what i that's
what i think that a lot of people
like espec even the younger people are
kind of looking at it like that
i don't care what your political values
are which is but the bigger issue is
when they're scared and it's a business
they say we don't want to lose half our
customers because they're freaking out
so bye-bye yeah
with gina carano i didn't know who she
was before the scandal
and bill burr is a superstar so like
they they look at their bottom line
they're like you know we can afford to
lose gina we can't afford to lose bill
it's mine well billboard is a comedy
superstar he's not like an a-list
hollywood actor in that context i mean
you know i don't know exactly what the
hierarchy looks like but it's
the little world i live in some of these
people we go oh god that's guys
the biggest guy in the world and then he
swears a lot yeah but matt damon walks
in and everyone goes oh
freaking matt you realize the difference
isn't the weirdest thing it's just like
why who cares obviously who cares but
that's just
the way the world is a really
interesting subject because um i don't
think we talked with ethan sipley
about this specifically on the show but
we did briefly touch on it i i wanted to
get into this more
but this idea that the traditional idea
of fame is over
because now you have hbo max i think
it's called hbo max
where they're doing simultaneous theater
releases and streaming releases
so people aren't going to go to the
movie theaters for these big movies and
spend
20 bucks per person anymore for the most
part they're gonna spend 20 bucks for
the whole movie and then watch it with
like 50 people at their house while they
order pizza or whatever
so why would someone cast tom cruise
brad pitt
you know who who's the person you
mentioned damon matt damon one of them
one of those one of those
two brothers you booked them because you
put their name on top of the movie right
yeah yeah and that way people see it in
the marquee and they see it in the ads
and they say ooh i want to go see this
and they go to the theaters
i think now that there's so many
different streaming services
so many different movies coming out like
i mentioned that one movie spiral came
out on shutter it just came out
i watched it it's not a blockbuster
movie but
all the movies are basically being made
equal at this point yeah sure they'll be
big marketing and big budget campaigns
how did that work out for a wonder woman
apparently wonder woman like fizzled and
made barely any money
because it was a streaming release yeah
and that's with me renting it 50 times
yeah i know and i you know i i i signed
up for 50 accounts to buy it because i
just love gal gadot no no but seriously
why pay gal gadot you know 20 million
dollars to do a movie
when you don't need her name on it
because it's not going to do that well
anyway
yeah especially when they've lost like
hollywood
mastered their star-making formula you
know the way that certain labels have in
the past or whatever like they were able
to
make her and then you know sign her to
these contracts and it was all part of
the system
so they bring people in and they make
them you know the next gal gadot
whatever it is right
but they're doing everything in their
power to like ruin
their vouch and their star system so
what when i go back to the younger kids
and i think me and you are around this
image we're in the middle
there's a lot of young people right now
that they've mastered they
they have these huge instagram accounts
youtube channels tick tock they know how
to make another guy
so like you know it talks about the nilk
boys you know i just think those guys
are interesting but they
they literally brought another guy in
brought him got him to a million
followers
got his channel to a million followers
then they're like we should start a
management company
they basically mastered star making the
same way that hollywood has
so just call it just at the same time
hollywood's wrecking their star making
because they go
check out this comic they're so funny
and everyone go huh they go what about
this one they go huh
and then everyone's like we gotta stop
paying attention so these guys are
wrecking their star making things think
about it same time everyone else is
figuring it out hollywood
is like blockbuster video they've
basically become
the old stodgy uncool
you know or they're becoming old stodgy
and uncool like you mentioned like kids
know how to
know how to be make stars themselves
they know how to use social media they
don't need the system anymore
but it's also the worlds are completely
separate
like the ad revenue system on
traditional media is so different from
digital media it's changing though
it's getting close like a lot of these a
lot of these places i mean
youtube is worth more than instagram and
you know it's all based on how people
buy but
it's not it's not that crazy different
well but but it kind of is check this
out
when you buy an ad on say tucker
carlson's show
you're not gonna get like the numbers
you get for tucker's ratings are an
estimate based on a sample size from
like nielsen
big boxes that no one's actually using i
mean so
you're hoping it's true yeah um and it's
probably close
with digital we know the exact number so
what happens is you know
the exact demographic of that number
well so with with the internet you can
refine your ads and really maximize your
price point and your and your profit
with buying ads on tv they basically
tell you here's how much it costs for an
ad
it's like you know that some websites
say it's like rachel matt's like
8 500 dollars for a commercial to run on
her you know on her channel
these advertisers will never have very
much money yeah you start a big business
go try to buy a commercial on logan
paul's podcast i'm sure right more than
that
absolutely way more than that i
guarantee you it's going to cost way
more than that
yeah so you and she's getting she gets
what like two to three million and
premium ads he's got nike i was watching
uh when you watch fox news i told you
this earlier but it made me laugh so
much that
they can't get good sponsors so they
have sleep apnea mask cleaner that's fox
they have the funniest ads like
orthotics uh you know remover
so i'll write this point up and then
we'll get into that a little bit
uh basically these advertisers spend the
eight grand
and then just look at their sales and
see if they go up
and then try and figure out if the ad
campaign worked with
online i can literally see people click
the link yeah i
know if the link is actually working
yeah so what's happening is in a lot of
ways
there's more ad space there's more real
estate for ads so the prices go down
but anyway at the rest the main point of
this is it's a totally different world
based on a lot of guessing and now it's
it's going away
it's becoming worth less and less and
less fox news is running pillow
commercials and sleep apnea commercials
rachel maddow's ads are are like i gotta
tell you man
and they're not even the parts that they
can and to go back to because you're so
right
but the even worse part of it is that
even the data they do
have they don't want to listen to for
other reasons
it's the equivalent of they go actually
this per
this is what they like there's a huge
market for this perspective the world's
craving
you know this perspective and then they
go what if we go with this one and you
go
this numbers are way higher on this one
we can't do that check this out i'll
give everybody some some top secret
information
so you can you can google search this
uh if you look up like cable channel ad
rates they say
i i just said rachel maddow because i
was looking into it it's like 8 500
i think for a 30 second 30 seconds do
you know how much it would cost you
for 30 seconds on
okay so so she gets like three million
viewers if you found a youtube video
with three million views do you know
what you would cost you to get a promo
spot in that youtube video
yeah three million sixty grand yeah that
sounds about right about sixty thousand
dollars if somebody can get
three million views per video they're
probably selling it for like 50 to like
75 depending on
where the ad appears and whether or not
they consider themselves to be a premium
brand that is better
and you don't have to film an ad you
just go hey also instead
of filming a billion dollar commercial
you go hey go check out you know tim's
beanies
yep so companies will say here's the
script promote it here's what we want to
see
and then the youtubers do all the work
like when we do the ads we i just read
and talk about the product
and so it actually costs less because
you don't have to make it i would say
that it costs more money probably
well it's hard to say depending on the
segment we do it can cost more money to
advertise on this podcast than it would
on rachel meadow
yeah easily that's crazy the old world
is in decay
yeah you know so so anyway the main
point of this segment because it's like
we've we've veered into a bunch of
different songs
i would never sign a contract with any
of these big networks if fox news
or cnn or any well if cnn and msnbc came
to me and they're like would you like to
sign i'd be like
surely you just if fox news came to me i
would also be like are you kidding
no not gonna happen i wouldn't sign with
any of these companies now for the
digital media ones
i think it's great that they're smarter
and doing better in their business
models
but you know you know what we're going
to do we're launching a new podcast soon
it's going to be crime cults mystery and
the paranormal it's going to be
evergreen stories not news related we've
got some
crazy stuff we're getting lined up it's
it's legit so we've got some like
like potential cult members and people
who
deny ever being in nicole yeah so it's
going to be like cool guess it's going
to be
like a bit of scripted but we're going
to start producing this content and
we're going to create a new site that's
going to be
you know non-partisan content so it'll
have talk it'll have con it'll have
jokes it'll have entertainment
and then we're going to create something
bigger and better than all of these
other platforms and it needs to happen
i want to build like like these
multi-channel networks kind of thing and
like start like an organization but i
want to make sure that the people that
we
sign and empower are are fully empowered
that we don't like end up ripping them
off with like
we own your content we own your ad
revenue like i want to give people an
old school bro i know that makes no
sense yeah think about this
there are a lot of companies that say
we're going to sign you
and you'll start a new youtube channel
and we'll pay you
but we keep the youtube channel and i'm
like why what happens in the contract is
up
are you gonna produce content let's
let's say someone signs you ian and
they're like you'll make a youtube
channel but we own the youtube channel
a year later the channel is dead it's
making like pennies
a month worthless and you don't produce
anymore
what are they gonna do are some like
executive gonna be like i'm john for the
ian channel
they tried doing it discovery tried
doing this i think it was now this
was it now this that sounds right they
bought discovery or something
and then or something happened and then
they changed it was like one of the
discovery channels turned into and now
this channel everyone's like we don't
want this we didn't subscribe to this
you can't turn netflix into amazon and
then expect everyone to be like okay
so so it's dumb now the way the
traditional media works saying
make a social media channel and we own
it great so in two years you'll have a
dead property that's stupid let the
person keep it as part of the incentive
package
i don't want to own it they're your
followers i'm not going to take your
twitter from you
but you know that these big cable
channels do this when you get hired they
make you create a new twitter
they own it's crazy yup it's like the
second potus twitter
the second potus yeah like the the
president has his old twitter and then
he gets his new
president twitter oh right right right
right yeah and then i have to transfer
it over
it makes sense to have in your contract
like you'll make the channel
and for the duration of our contract we
get the revenue from it and we control
it as if we did own it
upon your contract ending then well a
lot of ranges i guess they changed they
keep the show going without you that's
the other thing they reserve well but i
mean like a lot of these deals that are
happening now with youtube are like
we're gonna sign you to do a new youtube
show that you host because people really
like you and then we keep the channel
and i'm like
okay then keep the dead ip after i leave
it makes no sense
the deal should be yeah but then they
make they go uh tim cast
in uh irl hosted by dj qualls
dj kwalsk wow what a throwback to that
guy
where did that come from i just thought
it would be a good replacement
i was telling tim that dude i'd be
stoked to have him on the show that'd be
awesome
i want to do like build a network like
that where where you empower the user
to own their own content and to like see
them flourish but you just kind of
create like a seed organization that's
like an mcn a little yeah but like
inverted where you don't you're not in
it to rip these guys off you really want
to see them get because that's how you
attract the best people
you ask them they're uh wouldn't say oh
yeah we're in this to rip these guys off
right they all start like that well i
was involved with maker studios in the
early days
yeah a big one yeah i watched a lot of
the the contracts go awry like philip
defranco was part of it in the very
beginning and they were on all his
revenue and he was like why am i
realized pretty he was the first one to
realize like why am i doing all this
work and paying all this revenue to make
her when i could just be keeping it all
myself
peace guys so i took that as like i
learned my life i've had a lot of
conversations with these youtube people
and and you're kind of like
i go i don't listen i'm like a loopy guy
but i don't think i'm
stupid and then i like have these
conversations and they sell me the whole
pitch and i go
okay i just listen you talk for like 20
minutes and i like honest to god have no
idea what you're
what you're going for what do you guys
do like what do these companies do
like no and we have take your channel
and there's like tips and tricks and we
have we maximize this and maxima and you
go what are you talking about what do
you do
i have a i have a big announcement to
make ladies and gentlemen we are we are
here today
with ryan long on the spot i'm going to
make him an offer right now to to join
the new network now here's the deal
we're going to make a new channel and
we're going to call it ryan long comedy
2.
we own it we get all the money uh-huh
can you just tell me this is the worst
idea
no idiot would take this that's the joke
yeah
because but they keep it you can't have
it ian started talking but you're
working i will play ryan
making all the money and then jim's like
and i haven't forgotten about this
making all the money
and we're replacing you with ian yes oh
yeah what's the contract
no no we're just straight up doing it
we're buying you and then recasting you
with ian buying the ip yeah i'm in
ryan's long comedy it's a win-win
starring ian crossland
it's number two and it's uh you know
there's like a little poop emoji
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time